I have a very special uh guest Yasser I
have Gary Kasparov here once again with
me in the studio to look at the games
and share his impressions of the
tournament so far Gary welcome back to
the show um have you been watching the
games today
yeah I've been watching the games not
actually not much uh to watch but still
you know but they they try obviously
you look at the ding games for instance
he's tired yeah he's tired I mean he's
he's still probably trying to recover
psychologically from his victory
speaking of that that was the big game
yesterday nepo versus Ding and I think
we discussed it in the middle of the
game Nepal lost some of his Advantage
but still he had some chances he did not
put any pressure yesterday how did you
internalize that result
I think it's it's probably at one point
he just uh he just lost hopes and uh
actually he followed the line that we
discussed after rookie four yeah and he
just he recognized the take only four
and winning the pawn and the end game
might be
dangerous because black will have a
passport unless he decided that Troy's
okay uh and probably at that time he was
more thinking about where he missed his
chances so that's typically happens you
know you just you play the game but your
mind is yeah yeah you just think oh I
missed this and I missed that I just
yeah I think that's that was the case
yeah yeah let's discuss uh today's games
now for me at least to my eyes before
the games started this was an
interesting one the one between bogd and
Daniel Dak and alireza because you know
both of these players minus one they
don't have tremendous tournaments up to
this point another wrestle with the
black piece definitely wants to put some
pressure how uh how do you feel the
opening went on in this but naturally he
Bogdan played
because I think his plan was to push
alireza because you know he knew
allereza will try to to do something
yeah and and he just still tried to keep
uh you know position under control but
you know it's it's it's it was not as
dull and and and
uninterested as one could have expected
you know after Bishop with your Bishop
D3 actually the idea is just you know
because Paul 96 is a little bit you know
um at this point yeah
because yes H6 is not you know great
great uh um idea for black because it's
just for instance yeah
after Bishop D3 if you play immediately
then a black could go Bishop G6 that's
one and and stay there yeah another one
is Pawn on A7 is better better than than
H6 uh another as I tried Bishop before
but preparing E4 because that's clearly
after E4 white has slight Edge so for
example if you go Bishop yeah it's like
and actually A6 here is not no that's
not yes no no no not we're not very
useful I mean in theory now just enough
exchanges wise rule can appear on D3
Knight on the five Rook on G3 okay in
theories but you know it's it's it's it
might be a little bit you know just it's
uncomfortable so otherwise Play Bishop
before he tried to keep pressure and um
and um
yeah now this is interesting moment
because yes this is of the bishop before
1965 this is a trick uh-huh yes no
you're here so afterwards
but even even after Bishop yes Bishop
before you're still still at the five
still out there yeah yeah five if you do
take still you're not going to go Rook
B1 try to go forward
yes and uh and then just you know just
black is yes yes
so I think that was interesting so
that's why they created some
complications very nice yeah and uh um
B5
the problem is typically you know this
is you can make many active moves with
your pawns but there's one rule pawns
don't go back so that's why you know
when you attack it's like in in in in in
in military uh games and Battlefield so
you you create Witnesses in your Camp so
by by aggressively pushing you create
weakness on C4 it's a square so ideally
you know Black Knight could appear on on
the Square and uh and it could uh which
almost happened in fact yeah yeah
I'm sure he had some aggressive
intentions but he had to be very uh
creative because if if Bogdan takes back
the pool
he is his mother structure of course
must be the pawn on C6 is just so he has
to actually lose sipon but creatively
and that's and it was interesting so
this is he tried it right C3 now I
thought about Knight D1
yeah but Knight D1
and then he was 94. yes again this is
this is it's it's he cannot win the pawn
it does right yeah
you take a day two years and you don't
have time to take on Seasons yeah yeah
it's the
C5
all right try not D2 so he tried to give
the party yeah but but again because it
won't buy back in in a comfortable
situation yes because take take E5
so why not Knight C4 I thought this was
his idea yeah but he's still trying to
win I guess yes ah so with a five he's
three days three yeah and now we're five
years yeah yeah but it's this E5 again
that's why I do
yeah and he played um
E5 directly this is the position
yeah I
funny can you play Queen C2 here okay
let's take this and now E4 okay to play
it like this yeah
say I go here and now you just stop me
with F4
yeah
and I will go Knight D3 and you know
it's a nice spawn sacrifice yeah there's
any of this you can make but maybe we
should be six yes
yeah the thing is the Knight on B6
doesn't have work to go yeah but still
but still um
yeah
I don't want to take it we'll take C5
it's an interesting position
yeah it's again it seems that this
position is it looks very simple but
many but this is the problem or the time
17 minutes for that move 23rd exactly
that's that's that's a problem that's a
lot timing time time time time time time
oh by the way you know this is the what
about playing E4 immediately oh okay
I'll take this
technique
and just play like this I will take it
up on back yeah yeah
good night A4 probably yes Knight A4
Rockets is six
and then just defend like this and then
the bishop goes on I guess
that Knight on C3 is gonna be pretty
good yeah and you cannot touch the
default yeah like this
yeah
still thinking all right uh by the way I
do think that Fabiano I'm not 100 sure
if they have repeated already but they
were going to repeat maybe we can get a
panoramic of the playing hole and maybe
we can see whether yeah
five people it's so you know quickly in
the opening and I was curious because
and you guys this is the game that it
says the opening yes the CD4 is that's
what chronic player is yeah yeah in 1996
I lost the game actually this is because
it was
I was a novelty but just I was a bit
surprised it was a blitz library and I
lost the game so and I didn't manage to
win the game too so this was a final of
Moscow rapid in 96. and how did uh I
played Bishop E2 with purple but that's
exactly what I did now the freebies A6 I
I think I came back I came back but
black has a very comfortable position
very good
so he played Bishop D3 and Knight E5 and
by the way nepo was blitzing out his
moves maybe some residual preparation
from abortions
easy easy drawing yeah yeah
I almost felt like at some point he was
trying a little bit on Neville
probably not
and this is what we have right now lots
of exchanges nothing has changed the
position repeated once probably they
will repeat twice this is a pretty dry
um which one thing Iran we've discussed
that now yeah that was interesting so
that's the mvos H4 yeah
outside
what's your experience with this not
with H4 nothing was this position a lot
of experience yes a lot was H4 yeah
you've never played H4
I would say foreign
and then this is what we have right now
Bishop G5 make use of that age hormone
at least
and we are in this position right now
how would you assess it
any chances for white
maybe King D2 tried to invite rookie2
and King D3 or King C3
I don't think you can take right
they take before King D3 first
I mean this is with the a pawn running
and I don't see fire pretty strong it
should be five and then a pawn is
running
yeah maybe
maybe I can find the construction yeah
yeah
the bishop is good yeah
yeah the question is whether it's enough
or a serious advantage or not
so Rooker four Bishop also looking for
so I cannot start giving you checks and
pick up the pawn because I'm losing
peace
maybe you can do
you know yes
so here here
C2 yeah
it's pretty bad yeah that's a bad idea
bad and gain yeah
so
he played King too
but he wants to keep this King there yes
yes
still some pressure it feels like
yeah so I think oh sorry this is
he has to go because otherwise
maybe drop the bishop back but you just
got there you just played Bishop 3.
some pressure for for white yes what
about timing
34 minutes for MPL 26 minutes doesn't
seem like they're headed towards any
sort of time but it's probably almost
unpleasant so I think this is you you're
worse it's probably a draw yeah but you
don't know how to make a voice yeah you
have to fight and now he has to decide
whether he goes for this just for this
exchange I think it's probably
Knight you know you have to open the
position here so yes make a disbalance
uh by the way uh we're being told that
Richie versus Wesley are repeating right
now let's see where the repetition is
equal to H5 King G2 rookie five
um are we seeing a handshake right now
or
is the big question can Richie try for
more with H4 H4 you go G5 right
so now you cannot
take
yeah Richard is still trying to find
something I don't think he's going to
but playing rusi too but that doesn't
make much sense yes
you can play by this but
but so what's next yeah what's next so
Knights cannot go from B Street to C4 by
Magic yes the violation of the rules yes
you would love together yeah yeah yeah
no so can I do Rook E1 and then Rook C2
right now but that doesn't work either
seems like they're stuck in this
position
repetition is incoming
um and the final game I actually think
we've seen most of the games
it's okay the
other Reserve it's probably the most
interesting one so that's uh that's the
that's that's the one oh some stuff has
happened 34 immediately yes it did
now he has to go back on T8 already a
queen gets trapped you have to go back
on d8 and then maybe I don't know
51 Rook D1 or
yes or maybe ninth 93 first 93.
I like it yeah so we'll see sixes
there's some pressure yeah that Bishop
on C7 if you don't find a good spot for
it so yeah and where is the good spot on
F6 I think that's not really yeah so E4
yeah yeah I like this yes
we have this on the board right now
nice Advantage for bogdon
not a lot of risk yeah this is no that's
no risk no risk at all yeah yeah no risk
at all because Black Knight on B6 is
um yeah it's not uh it's not ideal
located let's say diplomatically yes
yeah yeah yeah
interesting position definitely this one
developing nicely
um still long time but he's accustomed
to it that's his usual playing style
Gary thank you very much for joining
what are your plans for the your living
Bucharest tonight is that correct or
tomorrow morning or early morning so
that's the
go back to New York I have a few events
there in New York and then fly back to
Europe you're excited about having
Magnus in Poland in a couple of weeks
we're great here so see Michael's back
at chess board though it's not classical
chess but yeah still entertaining so I
know
um see all of you guys soon also yes
absolutely Gary thank you very much for
joining us
and we will be going on a short
commercial break be before we return
with the rest of the games